[Applause]
here we go we're back
[Music]
[Applause]
28-18 lakers on top carmelo anthony
oh bridges knocked it away monk got it
back kicks it out anthony
hits the three
[Applause]
it's been a scene between the lines
and the times courtside
[Applause]
anthony
hits the three
to be in the fourth quarter
and a 15 point game with 139 to go
anthony gets free will take and connect
from three
[Applause]
deep down
yes sir
[Applause]
it stops the floor spreads you can run
and you can finish the lakers by five
huh
lake joe back to action as we just get
underway carmelo again from the corner
from reeds this time
79-77 but then braun came right back and
nailed the three it's a big shot for the
lakers here's carmelo got it
oh it's out to uh carmelo carmelo
looking to become number nine all time
he's
got it
passes below
it's twice as long
oh good move by reeves gets in the pink
open as carmelo this is the shot yes sir
kicker right now he's gonna have to go
in the game lebron little one-on-one
finds carmelo spot it up and score it
i'll tell you something
wow
he's been on the floor for 22 minutes
carmelo has 24 points
in that span and he has this crowd on
well they double the shea at the top i
didn't understand why and that tweet
updo it as he just took it to the basket
and it's crunch time now anthony got it
carmelo
and it's back to four comes on a little
extended run ball take by reeves corner
carmelo's in the game and melo
immediately gets the lakers three points
closer
two and a half to play in the third
again the lakers are allowing the
opposition to shoot 50 percent carmelo
yes sir
i'd rebound anthony davis
took it away only two turnovers this
quarter for the lakers for the lead
for the lead card
[Applause]
without a scratch
into the corner carmelo yes sir
about four or five steps i thought he
did
carmelo for three again
anthony
lakers have
the same five on the floor they want to
make sure carmelo look out
red hot
they still allow the third most and
they're going up against a high-paced
team carmelo
that's why he's a favorite here and a
few moments ago this one's going to be
taken away the bounce and westbrook
hustles back with that speed now the
lakers have a five-on-three mellow got
it
dance your way back
carmelo lakers have so many different
guys that can help protect the rim block
party so far carmelo again love it
love it
knock it down
there's not a lot of space over there
lebron
down ran a couple with how many steps he
runs knock it down again carmelo and a
four-point opportunity
really as lebron gets away with about
two steps extra
carmelo another catch and fire
got touched on the elbow so that's going
to be a four-point opportunity
mellow with 14 points in seven minutes
he forced that to be a tougher shot than
it would have been
and now russ drive hit card mellow in
and out and back in again
they're tying a career high for him
lebron had four steals in game one of
his two-game set melos on its way the
car that's mellow that's an impossible
three hey
give me a difficulty factor here oh man
it's got to be about a eight i mean that
one's not easy if he could shoot knock
this one down
that's going to be short taken by lebron
the outlet goes to carmelo he's going to
fire got it
carmelo
alfie shaggoon on this end of the floor
sixth in the entire nba and steals
two he can be a pest on the defensive
end carmelo
[Applause]
walt dwight
what a start for dwight howard as he
comes in to start the second quarter as
he normally does
melo
start in this game yeah he was but uh
collectively as a team they weren't
that's why when one guy is dominating
the story you worry about what happens
when he's not in the game bounce rondo
raja boy's going to bring it back out
didn't he
pretty smart player
anthony
got it
[Applause]
is not your friend anthony gets it right
back to russ another must basket here
anthony yessir
carmelo
next the second death lodge
if it happened
[Applause]
rush screen
very easily could have been a moving
screen on rust they let play on and
the basket counts one point game with
eight point eight
but we're back to who do you foul for
the lakers better foul and sign some way
to foul they tried that the last time
didn't foul anybody and dork got it done
let's remember this
right now the lakers get the ball inside
the a.d
rondo to carmelo anthony
three ball is down and the lakers in
front by two i mean
no indecision whatsoever as soon as he
caught it right up into his shot
feeling it great rhythm
possibly rozier's got nine of his 11 in
the second quarter
three seconds separating the shot the
game clock and
carmelo anthony
with the answer
oh it's done a great job on the boards
here tonight richards lost the handle
lakers hold serve despite three chances
shovel pass over to anthony it's down
carmelo
12 turnovers for charlotte second foul
on bridges he's been quiet tonight
probably almost to steal now davis on a
run davis kicks it
carmelo anthony got it
that would really disrupting the action
there the hornets westbrook finds
anthony he puts it up anthony hits oh a
tough shot i believe it's on howard
and right here mello just with miles
bridges in his faces gives it up one to
shoot got to get it up man what a stand
monk out of the pack carmelo anthony
number six
you bet
he's six made three for number seven
davis with a board
he's got 12 rebounds gives it up anthony
steps into one now and it's good